yeah hello and welcome to this video
yeah I was trying to get a rapid game
but nothing unfolded so I decided to
make one of those quick bullet videos
yeah I'm not going to do this like
everyday but once in a while I think why
not do a quick bullet video this is some
yeah 1+0 em and they don't have one plus
one unfortunately in the tournament that
would be really my time but okay we have
like ten seconds to go and should
actually join the whole thing nine eight
seven six five four three two one zero
okay so on the teeth I can join this
thing okay probably cover this verse 36
is slightly annoying but I was speculate
that he didn't do it okay so yeah it's
roughly equal I guess tries to get some
pressure but gives me you three so I'm
entering here looks dangerous for white
you can actually take the bishop is a
really long diagonal gonna be - does
that look know that should work okay so
check
and now why should fall apart there's a
mate threat and everything is hanging
taking g3 look at three would lead to a
cube checkmate take Quint eggs
this is awesome this is matron
okay it was a bit of a boy I think that
takes part eggs and made on f2 would be
would have been queued okay so I won
this game and have a good start I still
don't have a good kind of feel for when
I'm able to go this what is called the
Burger King fingers are oftentimes like
these kind of openings where you have
the problem that you might win but you
don't win quickly hit okay so I'm going
to climb on it it's not the best best
move maybe but it's it's easy to play
and just in this format I'm investing
lots of time maybe you can take on you
[Music]
know interesting that's a good move
yeah I cannot chick with the night and
if I go back this 93 okay
I'm getting me for ultimately 96 very
good game a black coming I didn't play
well quite clearly but he did a good job
much like that I didn't lose this piece
it could have really happened I'm not
sure that there was something that very
likely there was a one very slow
good move but I need to move quickly I
don't know how I want this on time but
somehow I did move yeah I'm not doing
this too often so good game and maybe
I'm getting into stride after a couple
of games playing late
this is like an opposition their hand on
the pound a million times to look really
good for white yeah he kind of hangs on
for a moment but it's not really good
like I'm a dead slow position is good of
course with from hand on the clock
actually it just felt very slow down
have to get used people continuing all
kinds of stuff on time not on time but I
mean it's this bullet yeah not
criticising him just a different country
teach with the bishops he did it's not a
bad move
yeah I don't like this is not the type
of position I usually play
not show this good even I need to gain a
bit of time
yeah that's an easy thing to play if you
die in a bullet game not sure that this
wins for white but it is very dangerous
probably this winning games are
objectively speaking so he wants to take
them Queen you force the idea she found
I check militant with no time on the
clock
hmm okay jump get a pause no still
slowly someone okay head pulling place
total crab opening and my promos prevent
me from killing you immediately
I mean piece up it's still still have to
coordinate a little bit but this is just
a four piece you okay so he resigned and
somehow I met you because too much you
can play me okay he has to watch out
damn on those for those weaknesses it's
not so easy okay ninety-two was a threat
be five I have ninety six that should be
okay okay I have to go back and now
maybe five is actually possible seem
says so he has untangled himself down
not good don't black lines as well but
I'm surprised about this
so after all this I'm getting a better
ending
we need ending for that man 12 seconds
though bring the sweet home back and I'm
like I have to take I have to try stupid
huh not winning this is not good
I could have just taken me five in that
friggin ending ah okay
yeah 1-0 it's not what I do on a daily
basis yet if I have looked anymore more
problematic this is also not easy for me
when I have Abbott here my development
is kind of okay because now can check
him
yeah chicking is not immediately winning
I can try this no not good okay I'm too
slow he just takes this I don't like my
technical player but okay maybe I
should've taken with the other pawn it
is generally okay here when I have high
6s better okay I'm place the only move
that makes no sense you can sell never
was a good move of course ok I'm back
into third place and I don't quite know
why but was probably cause I'm so lame
okay I need a quick win this is one way
to maybe get it can also do this of
course but it feels it feels interesting
let's direct the check
it should be should be dangerous rating
but how maybe triple C and it's actually
better half threatening made in two ways
so cannot cannot defend it
yeah I'm not I'm not winning quickly
enough yeah that's not only super it
okay let's to the eyes okay
I was thinking okay now I'm playing
quickly but not snot well this is quite
reasonable
oops oops
[Music]
stupid stuff we have to make it all
pretty bad okay
so nine minutes left okay so I read it
guy wow that looks like completely
unplayable for what
I'm just just killing a man ready for
Bishop a6 now I don't see what he is no
move against that I cannot put something
on the two because of made so used to
allow this I can take this is stronger
it's giving it easy okay I can give the
chicken
and I wanted to mail of course but
okay so I've won that one I don't even
know what's that one of the guys
competing for first didn't really follow
that this is actually an ending I can do
something and under some circumstances
if I can get this activity going on I
have four and so on it's symmetric
college you can maybe get something
going
it looks nice for example this and I can
just take you fall take here I'm taking
c4 I mean it said it's a good pawn maybe
ninety four is something gets to the e6
pawn here
cheeks and play for each for those are
nice very far apart I have got to put
the wrong phone x-ray to the Supersport
okay so I want that one time and it's
closed out this guy is somehow competing
yeah probably probably my Knight f3 is
too slow I wanted to take back at
players play for all that's crazy okay
in this position it doesn't really
matter that much that I lost all that
Tempe I was crazy
Wow it was funny allowed him to check
would be true my it's not a not a big
deal actually this I like now 21 2005 or
this one looks extremely problematic
look h4 is the threat Knight takes Queen
f6 and make the case fun okay
I am still just sharing with Auditor can
you please pair me with auditor or Wow
now two people yeah I don't get enough
games and I mean I'm not scoring badly
I'm not deserting success - maybe this
is the thing give me a game place okay
that's one of those people one D people
just move things you have to be
reasonably quick I could have played the
CAPTCHA already didn't do it now we
should have won a ball moves now we can
actually win this on right okay the
position opens up which is oftentimes
already at the end for those guys cause
we have to calculate so this whoop will
be trapped I hope doesn't seem to be
that's extremely lucky Wow okay now I'm
threatening 25 this is a good good file
manager
that's it probably okay so yeah the
problem is do I get a game and can I get
a point I mean very quickly I actually
very to play em not easy
[Music]
too much you probably one of those
people would overtake me which I'm
spoiling us
that's crazy
hey but I think I'm good it was tough
[ __ ] huh probably then what do they do
the account lower game no.1 number of
games probably I think didn't I think I
didn't did I lose again
probably not yeah I'm reasonably happy
winning is good yeah not doing this all
that often I hope you enjoyed this this
quick ride on the bullet